Hey Thoughty2 here. In 1789 Benjamin Franklin
wrote a letter to French Physicist Jean-Baptiste
Le Roy. In the letter he wrote “Our new
Constitution is now established, and has an
appearance that promises permanency; but in
this world nothing can be said to be certain,
exceptdeath and taxes.” And he was correct,
taxes are a pain, death doubly so. Mortality
is inevitable, it can be prolonged, if we
eat enough green foods and do enough squats,
or so our mothers tells us. But eventually
enters entropy; The second law of thermodynamics
states that everything that is ordered will
return to disorder. Due to entropy our ordered
system that we call life, must eventually
decay into chaos and thus death.
So what happens when our time is up? And I’m
not just talking about the physical effects
of death. More importantly, where do we go?
If anywhere. Now, there are 4,200 religions
in the world today and all of them have a
slightly different opinion of the afterlife.
But in truth only one group of people actually
knows what happens when you die and that’s
the dead. So let’s ask them shall we? No
really, let’s ask them.
You see there are a group of people who claim
to have died and then come back to life. And
they’re not a small group of people, in
America alone, eight million people claim
to have had an NDE, near death experience.
Many of whom claim to have passed over to
the other side and experienced something,
before being dragged back into the real world
again. So what did they experience? Did they
catch a glimpse of what really awaits us all
beyond the grave?
In 2011 a man was mid-way through major surgery,
but it went wrong and he quickly bled out,
he was declared dead for several minutes.
Amazingly the surgeons managed to revive him.
He described his minutes in the afterlife
like so: "I woke up in what looked like space
but there weren't any stars or light. I wasn't
floating so to speak, I was just there.”,
he also said that he felt nothing, he wasn’t
hungry, tired, cold or hot, he just felt peace.
“I knew there was light and love somewhere
nearby but I had no urge or need to go to
it right away” he quoted.
Another case tells of a college student who
overdosed on sleeping pills in his dorm room.
Paramedics came quickly but during the ambulance
ride he was clinically declared dead for three
minutes. When he awoke he described seeing
his own unconscious body inside the ambulance
and he witnessed himself flatline. Was he
actually seeing his own body as a spirit or
was it just an unconscious hallucination?
Amazingly the patient was able to describe
the paramedic inside the ambulance and could
even recall her name, despite not physically
seeing her before or after he fell unconscious.
A similar story of an outer-body experience
comes from a boy, who when 8 years old, drowned
at his local swimming pool, in the deep end.
He suddenly awoke, stood at the opposite end
of the pool, where he witnessed two lifeguards
pulling his non-responsive body out of the
water. He saw them attempt CPR for five minutes
on his own body, without any success. He watched
himself get put onto a stretcher and followed
himself on-board the ambulance all the way
to the hospital. Whilst aboard the ambulance
he started to feel a warm motherly presence
urging him to wake up and after a few seconds
he had returned to his body and was brought
back into the real world. He noted that waking
up from his deathly state felt like being
shot through a cannon at the swimming pool
where he drowned and landing inside the ambulance,
several streets away.
There are thousands of these stories from
around the globe and everyone experiences
something slightly different. So researchers
compiled a list of the most common experiences
people claim to have felt when declared clinically
dead then brought back to life:
Most people feel a rapid transit inside a
long and dark tunnel. Many have an out-of-body
experience where they can see their own body,
usually from some distance away, although
their body has different characteristics to
what they knew during their lifetime and appears
to be very different in nature somehow. They
witness every attempt being made on their
physical body to bring them back to life.
They often sense a warm presence or meet their
relatives who urge them to return to the world
of the living. There is usually a boundary
that represents the border between life and
whatever is beyond life, that seems to draw
closer and closer.
So many people have an out of body experience
but not everyone. Many people experience a
deep, intense blackness, or slip into a strange
other-dimensional void where they no longer
feel anything but are still aware of themselves.
Others tell of being able to see time as a
physical object that they can browse through
and even manipulate. As if their whole life
is pages in a book that they can flick through
at will.
So there we go, surely all these thousands
of accounts of some kind of afterlife, is
well proof that there is something beyond
what we know. Hmm, unfortunately we shouldn’t
be so hasty to make that call. Through his
research, Dr. Rick Strassmanbelieves that
all these near death experiences are actually
fictitious hallucinations in the brain caused
by a psychedelic drug called DMT.
DMT has a long history of making people see
things that aren’t really there. Amazonian
tribes have been taking a natural, homebrewed
form of DMT, called ayahuasca for hundreds
of years, as part of their healing rituals.
After death, the tissue of the Pineal gland
decomposes very quickly, releasing substantial
amounts of DMT around the body; you see DMT
is actually produced naturally inside our
bodies.
In 1993, professional drug-taker Terence McKenna,
seriously he made a living by taking psychedelic
drugs and writing about his experiences, said
the following about DMT “You cannot imagine
a stranger drug or a stranger experience.”
In fact, DMT is the most powerful hallucinogenic
drug there is. Now I think if a small amount
of DMT can make you hallucinate that you’re
Mexican and you live inside a taco then I’m
fairly confident that it’s powerful enough
to make you have an out of body experience
during an episode of temporary mortality.
Furthermore, research has shown that the events
that are experienced by a person during a
near death experience are very similar to
what people experience when they take DMT
recreationally, stuff such as passing through
a tunnel and having an out of body experience.
So the case is strong that this naturally
occurring drug could be responsible.
Understandably, people who’ve had these
experiences aren’t usually too pleased with
this explanation, because to them it felt
so real. Many people say their brief encounters
with the afterlife actually felt more real
and tangible than the real world. But DMT
is an extraordinarily powerful drug, it causes
us to hallucinate by actually firing the neurons
in the brain associated with these particular
visions, so in a way these people are actually
seeing these events. But what is seeing? In
truth our brain is capable of making us see
anything it wants us too, even if it’s not
really happening in front of us. As well as
interpreting the data entering our brain via
our eyes our brains can also completely make
up visuals, and we have no way of telling
apart the real visions from the fake. So it’s
a good job that most of the time, our brain
plays nicely. Or so we think it does.
Death is a complicated process, it’s not
as black and white as you see in movies. There
are actually two stages to death, the first
is clinical death. This happens as soon as
the patient stops breathing and their heart
ceases to pump blood. This usually lasts for
up to six minutes, during this stage the major
organs are still alive. These minutes are
crucial, and if a patient can be revived during
these six minutes they can avoid permanent
brain damage. After six minutes however comes
the second stage of death, biological death.
The organs begin to shut down and cells start
to degenerate.
Within 12 hours the skin loses its colour
and rigor mortis sets in, making the body
rigid, freezing it in place. This is caused
by calcium leaking into the muscles which
causes them to contract and tense up. But
something even stranger happens at the exact
moment of death. As was discovered when Dr.
Duncan Macdougall conducted a macabre experiment
in Massachusetts on 10th April 1901.
He gathered six dying patients, somehow. And
put them onto specially made beds that were
also very precise weighing scales. He observed
the weight of each patient very closely at
the exact moment of each of their deaths.
What he noticed was that at the exact moment
of death each patient lost 21 grams of weight.
Macdougall factored in every other form of
weight loss that could possibly occur at the
moment of death, such as sweat evaporating
from the body and the final breath exiting
the lungs, but nothing came close to accounting
for the 21 grams of instant weight loss.
Macdougall’s only explanation was that something
we couldn’t see had suddenly left the body,
could it be the patient’s soul? Does the
human soul weigh 21 grams? Well we should
take Mcdougall’s results with a pinch of
salt because his experiment had a few flaws.
Firstly, six patients is nowhere near a large
enough sample group to get a reliable result.
The weight loss has also been blown way out
of proportion, only one of the patients lost
21 grams, three other patients lost weight
of different amounts and two of the patients
were excluded from the results because of
mechanical failures with the equipment. Also
the scales that Mcdougall was using were only
accurate to 6 grams anyway.
So Mcdougall’s experiment shouldn’t be
trusted entirely, but it’s certainly interesting.
Something must have happened at the point
of death to trigger the scales to alter their
readings. The experiment hasn’t been repeated
since on more modern equipment because apparently
it’s now unethical to pop Gladdis on a weighing
scale just before she kicks the bucket.
Modern studies have been conducted to try
and uncover the secrets of the afterlife,
although they have tended to be less practical
than Mcdougall’s experiment. Recently the
British teamed up with some Germans and studied
2,000 cardiac arrest patients who had been
declared clinically dead and then resuscitated.
40 per cent of the participants reported having
a conscious awareness whilst they were technically
dead, many of whom said they had an out of
body experience and could see themselves from
a third-person point of view. Of particular
interest was a 57-year-old man from Southampton,
who was able to accurately describe everything
that happened to himself and every procedure
the doctors carried out on his body after
his heart had stopped. He could even recall
how many times the life support machine beeped.
He apparently saw everything from the corner
of the room. According to the doctors present,
everything he said happened, really happened.
The scientists involved in the study concluded
that some of the patients accounts of what
happened whilst they were clinically dead
were so frightfully accurate that therer indisputably
is life after death, and went as far as to
say they had “confirmed” the existence
of some kind of afterlife. Others are more
critical and simply blame the patient’s
experiences on DMT, claiming they were simply
hallucinating whilst unconscious.
In truth we have no way of knowing for sure
what happens when we’re laid to rest, and
we will probably never find out, until our
time is up. But does it really matter? Sure
it might be interesting to think about, but
spending one’s precious time trying to answer
an unanswerable question is ironically just
a waste of life. So if you think about it
by watching this video I’ve just wasted
several minutes of your life, sorry about
that. Thanks for watching.